[Música]
y llegamos a la capital española madrid
ahí está nuestra enviada especial a la
cumbre de la otan esther herrera este es
la saludo muy buena tarde le pregunta
entonces que se espera el día de hoy
digamos previo al inicio oficial de esta
cumbre de la otan en madrid de que ha
ocurrido en esta primera jornada cuando
ya han llegado varios mandatarios
buenos dias raúl las 10 poco a poco los
líderes de la alianza poco a poco se
están acercando a la capital española
aquí por ejemplo ya se está empezando a
acercar el presidente de eeuu joe biden
que viaja directamente desde la cumbre
del g7 de momento y han empezado los
primeros actos un encuentro entre el
secretario general de la otan james
ponte merkel presente el gobierno
español pedro sánchez en que ambos han
coincidido de la gran importancia de
esta cumbre a la que han considerado de
gran importancia decisiva incluso
fundamental y que se produce justo
después de la invasión de ucrania en que
el mundo ha cambiado por completo ha
insistido el secretario general de la
otan el mundo ahora es mucho más
peligroso e impredecible
luego está todo también en blog los
momentos espera que puedan el secretario
general de la otan de nuevo sobre estas
grandes prioridades desde esta cumbre y
luego por la noche hora local los reyes
de españa ofrecerán ya uno de los
primeros actos oficiales con la llegada
de todos los más mandatarios al palacio
real habrá una cena la capital española
ya está preparada de hecho ya hay
importantes disrupciones en el tráfico
de la capital esther que es la espera
digamos en materia general líneas
generales de esta cumbre
sí pues como comentábamos hay máximas
expectativas por varias razones sobre
todo por el momento tan complicado que
se produce como estábamos comentando
primero se espera que se apruebe una
ampliación desde el flanco oriental de
la alianza para empezar se va a pasar de
las 40.000 efectivos que hay de fuerza
rápida hasta 300.000 efectivos de una
brigada a un movimiento en el flanco
oriental que no se había producido desde
la guerra fría por otra otra cuestión
está también la vista puesta en el sur
en el titán
de la alianza algo que está insistiendo
mucho españa para proteger también a la
alianza en la parte del sahel pero algo
también muy importante para a francia se
esperó además la aprobación de un
paquete de ayuda a ucrania como
comentábamos es algo en un momento muy
complicado debido a su invasión de ayuda
quiso verdad sobre todo será financiera
pero también militar se va a hablar
del envío de material pe sangre especial
tanques y también se hablará sobre todo
de la importancia de que se pueda
ampliar también a la alianza a todos los
países también están pensando en si
finalmente
dentro de la alianza ya han pedido la
candidatura pero recordemos turquía está
bloqueando insiste en que tanto
finlandia como suecia están protegiendo
a miembros del pkk el partido
nacionalista kurdo que turquía considera
un grupo terrorista se han estado
haciendo avances el secretario general
de la otan de echo auspiciará una
reunión entre los líderes de finlandia
suecia y turquía para intentar
desbloquear la situación de hecho el
presidente recep tayip erdogán el
presidente turco se va a reunir también
con representa eeuu joe biden con un
intento de desbloquear esta situación
porque el mensaje político es indudable
de que estos dos países puedan entrar en
la alianza y otra cosa empieza la que
también se va a hablar es el aumento del
gasto en defensa de al menos el 2% el
secretario general de la otan insistía
ayer que esto es un mínimo que no es un
techo y que todos los países tienen que
hacer un esfuerzo porque el momento es
ahora y muy espacial y muy especialmente
tras la invasión de ucrania